do you see southwest uh regional
attracted i sure did yeah we're just
[ __ ] around you're not gonna be back
today we're just [ __ ] with you why
because uh over a thousand flights were
getting canceled
so many [ __ ] fun i think well one of
the other major airlines was like yeah
we're not doing that either yeah they
learn the hard way yeah well you said
every every airline was on board at
first with that they were leaning that
way and then once they saw the backlash
of southwest yeah they're like because
it's a business yeah like they're like
it took a [ __ ] major hit yeah it's a
business i mean way to go guys like
what'd you think was gonna happen yeah
what the [ __ ] but i do think they're
gonna win this whole thing i think at
the end of the day they're already yeah
they're winning yeah yeah there's really
no way to unless you move to texas or
nationals i'm not it's not women i'm not
anti-vaccine yeah but i'm not i'm
anti-vaxx kids i'm anti-venom that's a
different story because kids don't i
just haven't seen any evidence but but
it's not to protect kids to protect the
teachers the the adults it's not we know
kids they don't suffer from yeah the
only problem with that is that teachers
get vaccinated and but here's here's a
problem with that teachers and have an
out so the teachers union which is like
the baseball union they're so powerful
teachers can get go hey i'm either going
to get vaccinated or you can test me
every day yeah so they have they have an
option kids do do not and they're trying
to pass it with fda to from you know
five year olds to twelve yes that's
gonna get so dicey and you'll get diced
so dicey right now though the one thing
i will say is that you need 10 vaccines
to go to a public school so my kids have
to have their vaccine that proof of
vaccine yeah i've heard this argument
here's the difference with that those
vaccines you're talking about polio
they're different all that [ __ ] but
they've also been they've also been
researched
for years and years and years yes how
long has this children's vaccination for
cove had been studied
about 10 minutes 10 minutes you can put
that in your kid you're going to take
that risk
not a [ __ ] chance yeah now in two
years or three years if it comes out
it goes through the regular protocols
i'm not anti-vaccine
i know you're not it's understandable
that parents like myself like you are a
little hesitant
because i think in many ways the
government hasn't communicated enough
they i don't trust i don't trust the
government i don't trust that
that the people in power have my best
interest in my or my children's destiny
they don't care i believe that ideology
in a lot of ways sort of their
philosophy their they're either they're
controlling what they want to push it's
a little bit more important to them